Everyone is stressed these days, but young people are feeling the stress of 2020 most acutely. In a survey conducted by the Harris Poll for the American Psychological Association, more than one-third of young adults ages 18 to 23, also known as Generation Z, said that their mental health was worse now than it was at the same time last year. That compares with just 19% of millennials, 21% of Gen Xers, 12% of baby boomers, and baby boomers and 8% of older adults who felt that their mental health had gone downhill since last year. Why are the stresses of 2020 hitting young people so hard? And how will that affect them
如今每个人都倍感压力，但年轻人对2020年的压力感受最为强烈。在美国心理学会委托哈里斯民意调查公司进行的一项调查中，超过三分之一的18至23岁年轻人（即Z世代）表示，他们的心理健康状况比去年同期更差。相比之下，只有19%的千禧一代、21%的X世代、12%的婴儿潮一代以及8%的老年人认为他们的心理健康状况自去年以来有所下滑。为什么2020年的压力对年轻人打击如此之大？这对他们会有什么影响？
both now and in the long term? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the link between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. If you enjoy speaking of psychology, the conversation doesn't have to stop when the podcast is over. Get unlimited access to hundreds of videos about the latest in psychology for just one low price by registering for access to APA's 2020 virtual convention. Start with some of our selected videos featuring psychology's biggest names discussing topics like COVID-19, racism, and stigma.
无论是现在还是长远来看？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。如果您喜欢《心理学谈话》，播客结束后对话不必就此停止。注册参加美国心理学会2020年虚拟大会，只需支付一笔低廉的费用，即可无限次观看数百个关于心理学最新进展的视频。先从我们精选的视频开始，这些视频汇集了心理学界的大咖，讨论COVID-19、种族主义和污名化等话题。
Or let your curiosity take over and use our on-demand library to explore any topic. Just go to convention. APA.org slash podcast. That's convention. .APA.org slash podcast. Our guest today is Dr. Emma Adam, a developmental psychologist and professor
或者让您的好奇心引领您，使用我们的点播库探索任何主题。只需访问 convention.APA.org/podcast。网址是 convention.APA.org/podcast。我们今天的嘉宾是艾玛·亚当博士，她是西北大学教育与社会政策学院的发展心理学家和教授。
in the School of Education and Social Policy at Northwestern University. She worked with APA on the Harris Poll on the Stress in America survey to include young people from ages 11 to 23 in our sample and help to interpret the data. In her lab, she studies how factors like school, family, and peer relationships affect teens and young adults' stress levels and how stress in turn affects their health and development.
她与美国心理学会合作开展了“美国压力”调查中的哈里斯民意调查，将11至23岁的年轻人纳入了我们的样本，并协助解读数据。在她的实验室里，她研究学校、家庭和同伴关系等因素如何影响青少年和年轻人的压力水平，以及压力反过来又如何影响他们的健康和发展。
Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Adam. Thanks very much, Kim. I'm delighted to be here. Let's start with the Stress in America report. Gen Z adults reported more stress and worse mental health than any other age group right now. Was that a surprise finding or was that what you expected the results to be? Well, it was partly a surprise and partly expected. So I was very interested in the teens and the Gen Z teens and the Gen Z young adults. And we've known for many years that stress and depression and anxiety have been increasing in adolescence.
欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，亚当博士。非常感谢，金。很高兴能来到这里。让我们从《美国压力》报告开始谈起。Z世代的成年人目前报告的压力和心理健康状况比其他任何年龄段都要糟糕。这是一个令人惊讶的发现，还是您预料之中的结果？嗯，这既有令人惊讶的部分，也有预料之中的部分。我对青少年和Z世代的年轻人非常感兴趣。多年来我们一直知道，青少年中的压力、抑郁和焦虑一直在增加。
And so we were expecting to see that continue into 2020. But the surprise was the size of the jump. and particularly for the Gen Z young adults. And also why, also the fact that the Gen Z young adults showed more stress, notably more stress than the Gen Z teens. Talk about the Gen Z teens. How are they doing and what are, they're feeling a little bit less stressed? Why might that be?
因此，我们预计这种情况会持续到2020年。但令人惊讶的是增幅之大，尤其是对于Z世代的年轻人而言。此外，Z世代的年轻人表现出的压力明显高于Z世代的青少年，这也是一个值得关注的事实。谈谈Z世代的青少年吧。他们的情况如何？他们感受到的压力似乎稍微小一点？这可能是为什么呢？
First of all, let me point out that teens haven't been tested every year in the Stress in America survey. Right. We've had really reliable data a year over year on adults, but there's only been teens tested for a few years. So their stress was not notably higher than in the past years that they've been tested. And that's a bit of a mystery of why that might be the case. But I have actually some other data that speaks to that question. One thing about the stress in America data is that it's cross-sectional, so it's different teens asked every year.
首先，我要指出的是，在“美国压力”调查中，青少年并没有每年都接受测试。没错。我们对成年人有非常可靠的逐年数据，但青少年只测试了几年。所以他们的压力并没有比往年测试时明显更高。为什么会这样还是个谜。但我实际上还有其他数据可以回答这个问题。“美国压力”数据的一个特点是它是横断面的，即每年询问的都是不同的青少年。
In my own research lab, the Coast Lab, the context of adolescent stress and thriving lab, we had a survey ongoing and we were able to test teens prior to lockdown and then the same teens again after the lockdown and ask questions about mood and sources of stress in their life. And what we've found is that for teens as a whole, the average stress level after lockdown didn't go up greatly, but when you break down and look at sources of stress, certain sources of stress went up and certain sources of stress went down. So it turns out that the stress of schooling, for example, actually decreased for teens because these social stressors and the stressors of schedules of schooling went down. But the stress related to home and health of family and friends and family related stress went up.
在我自己的研究实验室——海岸实验室（青少年压力与成长环境实验室）中，我们进行了一项持续的调查，我们能够在封锁前测试青少年，然后在封锁后再次测试同一批青少年，并询问有关情绪和生活中压力源的问题。我们发现，对于青少年整体而言，封锁后的平均压力水平并没有大幅上升，但当你细分并观察压力源时，某些压力源上升了，而某些压力源下降了。事实证明，例如学业压力实际上对青少年来说有所减轻，因为这些社交压力源和学校日程的压力减少了。但与家庭、亲友健康相关的压力以及家庭相关的压力却上升了。
And that went up dramatically, particularly for teens from low socioeconomic circumstances. So it's a story of stress changing for teens in terms of the sources and also of disparities in stress with lower income teens experiencing much greater stress as a result of the pandemic than higher income teens. How did these findings from the Stress in America survey fit with the long-term trends in teens' mental health? I've seen data that rates of depression have been rising overall among teens for close to a decade. Do you researchers have any theories as to why that's happening? Sure. This trend has been very concerning to researchers for the last decade. It's been really become apparent in the past few years.
而且这种压力急剧上升，特别是对于来自低社会经济背景的青少年而言。因此，这是一个关于青少年压力源发生变化的故事，也是一个关于压力差异的故事，即低收入青少年因疫情而承受的压力远大于高收入青少年。《美国压力》调查的这些发现如何与青少年心理健康的长期趋势相吻合？我看到的数据显示，近十年来青少年抑郁症的发病率总体呈上升趋势。你们研究人员对此有什么理论吗？当然。过去十年来，这一趋势一直让研究人员非常担忧。在过去几年里，这一点变得非常明显。
And there's, unfortunately, lots of theories, but no solid evidence regarding what is causing this trend. So some of the theories include increased social media use among teens. But the evidence has been very mixed on that. There is evidence that for some teen social media is a very positive influence. And for others, it can be more harmful. But it tends to be that the social media experiences, the online experience, The online experience of teens mirror the offline experiences. So teens that are doing well already in their interpersonal interactions tend to do well in their online interactions.
不幸的是，有很多理论，但没有确凿的证据表明是什么导致了这一趋势。一些理论包括青少年社交媒体使用量的增加。但证据对此非常不一致。有证据表明，对于一些青少年来说，社交媒体是一种非常积极的影响。而对另一些人来说，它可能更有害。但往往是青少年的社交媒体体验、在线体验反映了他们的线下体验。因此，那些在人际交往中表现良好的青少年往往在在线互动中也表现良好。
And those that are having difficulty also have more difficulty with online interactions. And there's also evidence of bidirectional effects so that when teens become more distressed, they might turn to social media sources more. So it's really hard to get any insights into causality there. There's also evidence that sleep is declined for teens, and that's a really possible candidate. Sleep has a large influence on mood and depression, and so with the increases in activities and increases in kind of school-related stressors that teens are facing, that both maybe one contribute to the increased stress and depression, but also chip away at sleep, which is something
而那些遇到困难的人在在线互动中也会遇到更多困难。也有证据表明存在双向影响，即当青少年变得更加痛苦时，他们可能会更多地转向社交媒体资源。因此，很难从中获得任何关于因果关系的见解。还有证据表明青少年的睡眠减少了，这是一个非常可能的候选原因。睡眠对情绪和抑郁有很大影响，因此随着青少年面临的活动增加和学校相关压力源的增加，这两者可能既导致了压力和抑郁的增加，也削弱了睡眠，而睡眠对于调节幸福感来说是非常重要的。
really important for regulating well-being. The final hypothesis, and this is one that's really relevant to thinking about stress in America, is that increased economic disparities in the family and in schools is contributing to increased stress and depression in teens. And this is where the stress in America data have me really concerned, because there is some pretty good evidence that larger economic terms, which in turn caused family economic conditions to worsen, in turn has effects on parent mental health and teen mental health and that there's some possibility that the past economic downturns have had long-term effects on atla, have contributed to the increase in depression and anxiety.
最后一个假设，也是与思考“美国压力”非常相关的一个假设，是家庭和学校中经济差距的扩大导致了青少年压力和抑郁的增加。这就是“美国压力”数据让我非常担心的地方，因为有相当好的证据表明，更大的经济波动导致家庭经济状况恶化，进而对父母的心理健康和青少年的心理健康产生影响，并且过去经济衰退有可能对长期结果产生影响，导致了抑郁和焦虑的增加。
And then there's some real evidence that this particular economic downturn may be having effects on teens. Going back to sleep, given that so many kids are attending school virtually right now, are they getting more sleep and might we expect to see their stress levels go down, at least as long as they're studying at home and not getting up in the morning to catch the school bus? Yeah, actually, we do have evidence, again, in the data from my lab, from a study called the bio study, that teens are sleeping more post-pondemic or during the pandemic, which is something that may account for why teens in particular aren't showing as high elevations
而且确实有一些证据表明，这次经济衰退可能正在对青少年产生影响。回到睡眠问题，鉴于现在许多孩子都在进行虚拟上课，他们是否获得了更多的睡眠？我们是否可以预期他们的压力水平会下降，至少在他们在家学习而不用早上起床赶校车的时候？是的，实际上，我们确实有证据，同样来自我实验室的数据，来自一项名为“生物研究”的研究，表明青少年在疫情后或疫情期间睡眠更多，这可能解释了为什么青少年并没有像我们预期的那样表现出那么高的压力水平。
and stress as we expected. So that's something that's definitely teens run up against, we're running up against relatively rigid school schedules. And the release of the rigidity of those school schedules allows teens to get more of the sleep that they need. And also allows them to sleep at times that they're better suited to sleep. There's a biological rhythm to sleep. And with teenagers actually having a biological circadian pattern
所以这是青少年确实遇到的情况，我们正在面对相对僵化的学校时间表。而这些学校时间表的僵化程度降低，让青少年能够获得他们所需的更多睡眠。也让他们能够在更适合睡眠的时间睡觉。睡眠有一种生物节律。而青少年实际上有一种生物昼夜节律模式。
where they are preferred to sleep later, go to bed later and wake up later. And the pandemic from many youth is allowing them to live within that biological rhythm that is more natural to them. So it's just the parents then who are having insomnia because they're worried about the economy and their jobs, right? Absolutely. And those Gen Z young adults as well. Yeah. You've written that there's this common idea that adolescence is by its nature a stressful time of life. But you also say that normalizing high stress for teens ignores the negative effects that it can have. What have you and other researchers found out about how stress affects teens' health and development? Sure. So my research has focused not only on perceptions of
他们倾向于晚睡、晚起。对于许多年轻人来说，疫情让他们能够按照更自然的生物节律生活。那么，只有那些因为担心经济和工作而失眠的父母，对吧？绝对是这样。还有那些Z世代的年轻人也是如此。是的。您写道，有一种普遍的观点认为青春期本质上是一个充满压力的生活阶段。但您也说，将青少年承受高压力常态化，忽视了它可能产生的负面影响。您和其他研究人员发现了压力如何影响青少年的健康和发展吗？当然。所以我的研究不仅关注对压力的感知，
stress, but also the implications of that stress for biological systems and for cognition and for health, both mental health and physical health. And so within my own research, and other people's research, there's really profound implications of stress for all sorts of aspects of biology. But the system that I've focused on is the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis, which is called the HPA axis, for short, or most of you may be more familiar with the hormone that's produced by that axis, which is cortisol. And we have done a diary research where we text teens at random moments during their day and get them to report on the types of stressors that they're encountering throughout the day and then link those with levels of cortisol
还关注这种压力对生物系统、认知以及健康（包括心理健康和身体健康）的影响。在我的研究和其他人的研究中，压力对生物学的各个方面都有深远的影响。但我关注的系统是下丘脑-垂体-肾上腺轴，简称HPA轴，或者你们大多数人可能更熟悉该轴产生的激素，即皮质醇。我们进行了日记研究，我们在一天中随机时刻给青少年发短信，让他们报告他们全天遇到的压力源，然后将这些与皮质醇水平联系起来。
the stress hormone. And what we've identified that there are very many, throughout the course of the day, this hormone is going up and down as negative move goes up and down and as teens encounters stressors. And that's perfectly normal to be expected and that's part of what the the system is supposed to do. When cortisol goes up, it helps to mobilize energy resources to help individuals cope with the stressor. The problem is when you start to get exposure to chronic stress. And so the chronic stress associated with poverty, the chronic stress associated with high levels of exposure to bullying or racial discrimination or abuse within the home or domestic violence, those ongoing stressors can really cause dysregulations in the biology, which
这种压力荷尔蒙。我们发现，在一天中，这种荷尔蒙随着负面情绪的起伏和青少年遇到的压力源而波动。这是完全正常的，也是预料之中的，这是系统应该发挥的作用的一部分。当皮质醇升高时，它有助于调动能量资源，帮助个人应对压力源。问题在于当你开始接触慢性压力时。因此，与贫困相关的慢性压力、与高水平接触欺凌或种族歧视或家庭虐待或家庭暴力相关的慢性压力，这些持续的压力源确实会导致生物学上的失调，这
in turn have implications for physical health. There's a wide variety of impacts on not only stress hormones, but on immune functioning, on early signs of cardiovascular disease. And then as we've been talking about it, has strong implications for emotional and mental health disorders. But the underappreciated impact also is that stress has, and these changes in stress biology have implications. for cognition. And so it is kind of, is, in my opinion, one understudied contributor to disparities in academic outcomes. If this stress, one thing that stress does to your cognition is it narrows it and focuses your cognition on the stressor at hand, which makes it really hard to focus your attention on things like algebra, which might be what the teacher is hoping that you're focusing on.
反过来又会对身体健康产生影响。它不仅对压力荷尔蒙有广泛的影响，还对免疫功能、心血管疾病的早期迹象有影响。正如我们一直在讨论的那样，它对情绪和心理健康障碍也有强烈的影响。但被低估的影响是，压力以及这些压力生物学的变化对认知也有影响。因此，在我看来，它是导致学术成果差异的一个未被充分研究的因素。如果这种压力，压力对你认知所做的一件事是它会缩小并集中你的认知在手头的压力源上，这使得你很难将注意力集中在代数等事情上，而这可能是老师希望你关注的事情。
So a wide range of implications both in the short term. And there's limited evidence in following teens looking at the long term, but we have every reason to believe that these short term implications, if chronic can turn into long run disease outcomes. What should parents or other caregivers be looking for as the signs that stress is harming their children? So stress is hard to detect because there is in teens, in some senses, because parents have this stereotype that teens will be teens and the kind of moodiness that teens that is a stereotype of being an adolescent can be dismissed as something that is just normal. I think teens, parents need to be willing to ask their teens how they're doing and regularly do so. It is a difficult thing to do. Teens may dismiss parents' interest in their well-being, but I think ultimately it's important to continue to inquire. There's also changes in behavior.
因此，短期内有广泛的影响。在追踪青少年观察长期影响方面的证据有限，但我们有充分的理由相信，如果这些短期影响是慢性的，可能会演变成长期的疾病结果。父母或其他照顾者应该寻找哪些迹象表明压力正在伤害他们的孩子？所以压力很难检测，因为在某种意义上，在青少年中，父母有一种刻板印象，认为青少年就是青少年，而青少年那种情绪化作为青春期的刻板印象，可以被视为仅仅是正常的。我认为青少年，父母需要愿意询问他们的青少年他们过得怎么样，并定期这样做。这是一件困难的事情。青少年可能会忽视父母对他们幸福的关心，但我认为最终继续询问是很重要的。行为也有变化。
If a teen is sleeping more than usual or less than usual, if their moods seem more more intense than usual, either more sad or more angry. Any large changes in behavior, if they stop going out to see friends, well, now in the pandemic, in the pandemic, that's hard to assess, but you can all, you can assess whether or not they are seeming socially withdrawn. Teens are connecting with friends virtually. If they seem to have drawn back completely from reaching out electronically to friends, and that would be another sign of distress in teens. And so basically large changes in behavior are something to be on the lookout for. And certainly sadness, crying, those are signs. But as I said, anger can be also an expression of depression in teens as well.
如果一个青少年比平时睡得更多或更少，如果他们的情绪看起来比平时更强烈，要么更悲伤，要么更愤怒。任何大的行为变化，如果他们停止出去见朋友，嗯，现在在疫情期间，在疫情期间，这很难评估，但你可以评估他们是否看起来社交退缩。青少年正在通过虚拟方式与朋友联系。如果他们似乎完全退缩，不再通过电子方式联系朋友，那将是青少年痛苦的另一个迹象。所以基本上大的行为变化是需要注意的事情。当然悲伤、哭泣，这些都是迹象。但正如我所说，愤怒也可能是青少年抑郁的一种表现。
You also study interventions like meditation and mindfulness to reduce teen stress levels. What have you found about effective interventions? What are the best that, what have you found that works best? Sure. Well, we have several interventions that are underway. So I hate to draw conclusions about them until all the data are in. But we do have one intervention where we studied meditation in teens. And we found significant reductions in blood pressure.
您还研究了冥想和正念等干预措施，以降低青少年的压力水平。您发现了哪些有效的干预措施？您发现什么最有效？当然。嗯，我们有几项干预措施正在进行中。所以我不想在所有数据出来之前就得出结论。但我们确实有一项干预措施，我们研究了青少年的冥想。我们发现血压有显著降低。
pressure among teens who were engaged in the meditation intervention. We're currently launching an app-based mindfulness intervention, which is something that we hope will have positive effects. We do know that mindfulness more generally, there's been prior studies that have tested mindfulness in teens and shown positive results, but what we're hoping to do is come up with something that might be a little more scalable, a little more easily accessible to a broad range of teens. The other type of stress that we've not touched on in too much detail is the stress of racial
在参与冥想干预的青少年中。我们目前正在推出一种基于应用程序的正念干预，我们希望这将产生积极的影响。我们确实知道正念更广泛地说，之前有研究测试过青少年的正念并显示出积极的结果，但我们希望做的是提出一些可能更具可扩展性、更容易让广大青少年获得的东西。我们还没有详细讨论的另一种压力是种族歧视的压力，这是我实验室的一个重点。因此，我们有一个专门的干预措施，旨在试图缓冲青少年免受种族歧视的压力。该干预措施实际上侧重于促进青少年积极的种族民族认同。这是一个基于小组的干预措施。我们现场做过。我们在Zoom上做过。它是由哈佛大学的阿德里亚娜·奥马尼亚·泰勒设计的。她的实验室有初步结果显示对青少年有积极影响，无论是在他们的自尊和情绪健康方面，还是在他们的一些学业表现方面。这个想法是，
discrimination, and that's a big focus in my lab. And so we have a specific intervention that is designed to try to buffer teens from the stress of racial discrimination. And that intervention actually focuses on promoting a positive racial ethnic identity in youth. And it's a group-based intervention. We've done it live. We've done it on Zoom. It was designed by Adriana Omania Taylor at Harvard University. And there's initial results from her lab showing positive effects for youth, both in terms of their self-esteem and their emotional well-being as well as some of their academic performance. And the idea is that,
这是一个更普遍的概念，我认为你可以从中得到启示，那就是归属感，感到被群体包容，感到被接受是调节压力最重要的事情之一。我们是社会性动物。因此，社会互动和归属感，感到人们关心我们，我们被群体包容，对于我们的人类生存确实是根本性的。因此，任何威胁到这一点的事情都是一个根本性的压力源。这就是为什么孤独是一个非常强大的压力源。这就是为什么种族歧视对青少年来说是一个非常强大的压力源。因此，这个干预措施旨在让青少年真正探索并以某种方式与他们的传统联系起来，这可能会支撑他们抵御一些
and this is a more general concept that I think you can take away from this, is that belongingness, feeling included in a group, feeling accepted is one of the most important things for regulating stress. We are social beings. And so social interaction and feelings of belonging, feelings that people care for us and that we're included in the group are really are fundamental to our human existence. And so anything that threatens that is a fundamental stressor. So this is why loneliness is a really strong stressor. And this is why racial discrimination is a really strong stressor for teens. And so this intervention is intended to have youth really explore and connect with their heritage in ways that maybe bolster them against some of the slings and arrows of
基于种族或其他类别的非常不公平的待遇。当然，最终目标是消除青少年生活中的这些压力形式。在此期间，我们还专注于增强他们应对这些类型压力源的能力。您知道哪种支持更有帮助吗，是来自家人还是朋友的支持？这会根据孩子的年龄而有所不同吗？当然。有一些证据，当然从理论基础上看，对于年幼的孩子，儿童和青春期早期更多地依赖父母的支持。当你进入青春期后期，来自同伴和社区的支持开始变得重要。但我不想削弱父母对即使是年龄较大的青少年和年轻人的生活有多么根本的重要性。
a very unfair treatment on the basis of race or other categories. Although ultimately, of course, to eliminate those forms of stress in teens' lives. In the meantime, we're concentrating on also bolstering their ability to respond to those types of stressors. Do you know which kind of support helps more, whether that's support from family or friends? Does that vary depending on a child's age? Sure. There is some evidence that, and certainly from a theoretical basis, with younger children, children and early adolescence depend more on support from parents. And as you enter later adolescence, support from peers and communities start to become important. But I don't want to diminish how fundamental parents are even to the lives of older adolescents and young and young adults.
因此，虽然在寻求外部同伴进行社交娱乐和某种形式的支持方面确实存在转变，但父母仍然是青少年和年轻人根本的依恋对象。我认为重要的是，特别是在这些受到威胁的时期，这种沟通和支持形式尽可能多地为年轻人保持开放。目前年轻人面临的最大挑战之一是许多高中、大学甚至小学和初中都在远程或混合模式下运作。这种转向虚拟学校的方式可能会如何影响青少年和年轻人的压力水平、心理健康，并最终影响他们的发展？
So while there's a transition in certainly seeking outside peers for and, and, entertainment for social enjoyment, and for some forms of support, parents remain a fundamental attachment figure for adolescents and for young adults. And I think it's important, particularly in these times of threat, that that form of communication and support remains open as much as possible for youth. One of the biggest challenges for young people right now is that many high schools and colleges and even elementary schools and middle schools are operating remotely or on a hybrid model. How might this switch to virtual school affect teens and young adults' stress levels, mental health, and ultimately their development?
所以这是一个我有点推测并利用理论来回答的地方。没关系。我确实拥有的一个数据片段是来自“生物研究”的数据，它确实向我们表明，转向虚拟或混合模式正在让青少年从学校的社会压力中得到一些缓解，并增加了睡眠和增加了平静感。所以我们实际上观察了疫情前后孩子的情绪状态。
So this is a place where we don't, where I'm speculating a little bit and drawing on theory to inform my answer here. That's okay. The one piece of data that I do have is the data from the bio study, which does show us that the switch to virtual or hybrid models is allowing teens some relief from the social pressures of school and increased sleep and increased feelings of calm. So we actually looked at mood states of kids before and after the pandemic.
因此，在疫情后学校关闭后，孩子们，青少年更孤独，但他们也更平静，更不累。但另一方面，来自低社会经济背景的年轻人，除了感到更平静、更不累和更孤独之外，他们还感到羞耻感和愤怒感增加。所以这些实际上不是由学校教育驱动的，而是由疫情的其他方面驱动的。所以我认为，当再次推测虚拟学校的影响时，真正重要的是孩子们正在获得他们需要的教育。从长远来看，他们需要适当的内容，教学需要适当调整
And so post-pandemic after the school shutdowns, kids were lone, teens were lonelier, but they were also calmer and less tired. But the other, on the flip side, youth from lower SES circumstances, in addition to feeling, calmer and less tired and lonelier, they were also feeling increased feelings of shame and anger. And so those were actually not driven by the schooling, but the other aspects of the pandemic. So I think that when just again speculating on the impacts of virtual schooling, what's really going to matter is that kids are getting the education that they need. for the long run, they need appropriate content and teaching needs to be adapted appropriately
以在虚拟环境中提供该内容。他们需要与同伴和老师进行适当的社会接触，只要能在网上促进这一点。在这一点上，我不担心屏幕时间，就像我担心确保青少年在教育和社交关系中具有连续性一样。因此，如果这些社交关系可以通过虚拟方式提供，我认为这对青少年来说非常重要。所以学校需要对他们提供教育的方式进行创新，也要对他们提供与青少年联系感的方式进行创新，这样他们才能真正体验到同伴群体，并体验到与老师的互动。所以我认为
to deliver that content in a virtual setting. They need appropriate social contact with their peers and with their teachers to the extent that can be facilitated online. At this point, I'm not worried about screen time as much as I'm worried about ensuring that teens have continuity in their education and in their social relationships. And so if those social relationships can be provided virtually, I think that matters greatly for teams. So schools need to just get creative about how they're offering their education, but also how they're offering a feeling of connection to teams so that they actually have an experience of a peer group and have an experience of interaction with their teacher. So I think it's
现在说在家上学的部分是否会具有破坏性还为时过早。我们当然，我更担心与因疫情健康危机而失去亲人相关的破坏，以及疫情对经济的负面影响。所以这些事情比虚拟学校更让我担心。当你谈到父母时，虚拟学校一直是一件极其困难的事情。所以我们在“美国压力”调查中确实看到父母也比非父母承受更大的压力。实际上，当我检查数字时，如果你问关于与疫情相关的压力，父母的压力几乎和Z世代的年轻人一样大。所以这两个群体在应对这场疫情方面确实遇到了困难。我认为我们已经做了一件事，
too soon to say whether the homeschooling part of it will be devastating. We certainly, I am more worried about the devastation associated with the loss of loved ones due to how the health crises of the pandemic and also the negative impact of the pandemic on, sorry, the negative impact of the pandemic on the economy. So those are the things that worry me more than the virtual schooling. And when you talk about parents, the virtual schooling has been. something extremely difficult to navigate. And so we did in the stress in America, the surveys see the parents are also much more stress
在这次采访中，我们已经分解了所有这些不同的压力源，但与这场疫情相关的真正问题或真正的危机是堆积起来并正在影响成年人和青少年的许多不同问题。有与疫情相关的压力，然后有与疫情相关的经济衰退相关的压力。有与疫情健康危机相关的压力。有与疫情健康危机相关的压力。然后有与2020年这个社会中非常现实的种族问题相关的压力，这些问题已经存在了几代人，但美国的种族关系在2020年确实再次成为焦点，黑人被警察枪杀和死亡。
than non-parents. And actually, when I checked the numbers, if you asked about stress related to the pandemic, the parents are almost as stressed as the DENZE young adults. So those are the two groups that are really having trouble navigating this pandemic. And I think one thing we've kind of done,
这是我们在调查中确实看到的，大多数美国人都对这些事件感到担忧。大多数美国人都对选举结果和选举周围的紧张局势感到非常有压力和担忧。所以我们关于压力所知道的一件事是，一次一个压力比压力积累更容易管理。有一种东西叫做累积压力模型，你基本上把一个压力源、另一个压力源、另一个压力源、另一个压力源加起来。对于许多人来说，有一个临界点，即一次处理太多的压力源确实会导致有问题的健康结果。我认为有趣的是，我们在“美国压力”中发现，总体而言，人们对未来感到积极，但Z世代中有一个例外，他们对未来说了什么？嗯，你知道，在“美国压力”调查中，每一代人都说当被特别问及时，他们对未来感到希望，但Z世代是其中最低的。我认为他们是64%，而其他人是70多。所以他们对未来有希望，但我认为在这个调查中定义Z世代的真正心理维度是对未来的不确定感。他们在调查中谈到，三分之二的人说为未来做计划似乎是不可能的或感觉
in this interview so far has broken down all these different sources of stress, but the real problem or the real crisis associated with this pandemic is the number of different issues that have piled up and are affecting both adults and teens right now. There's stress related to the pandemic, and then there's stress related to the economic downturn associated with the pandemic. There's stress associated with the health crises of the pandemic. There's stress associated with the health crises of the pandemic. And then there's stress associated with the very real issues of race in this society in 2020 that have been here for generations, but have really the race relations in the country have really come to the forefront again in 2020 with the shooting and death of black
是不可能的。而实际上只有51%的Z世代青少年这样说。所以三分之二的人觉得为未来做计划是不可能的，这是一种非常瘫痪的状态。而不确定性，我说过，社会排斥是导致生物压力的一个强大因素。另一个是不确定性。所以这些青少年既被社会孤立，又对他们未来的学校教育和未来的工作感到极大的不确定性。我认为，你知道，这确实令人担忧。我有一位同事，汉娜·施万特，她实际上研究了个人在经济衰退中毕业的影响，并发现经济衰退中毕业对终身收入以及甚至家庭组建和健康结果等事情都有终身影响。所以我认为，除了提供我们知道青少年和年轻人所需的各种情感支持外，我们还应该非常仔细地思考我们可以提供什么样的经济支持，什么样的职业培训计划，什么样的机会。我今天早上在进行头脑风暴，思考，那么“美国服务队”怎么样？你知道，我们能扩大“美国服务队”吗？不仅为在这一困难经济中毕业的青少年和年轻人提供机会，而且提供对我们整个国家都有帮助的机会。
individuals at the hands of police. And that was something we did see in the survey that the majority of Americans were concerned about those events. And the majority of Americans are very stressed and concerned about the outcome of the election and the tension surrounding the election. And so it's the one thing that we know about stress is that one stress at time is more manageable than accumulation of stressors. And there's something called a cumulative stress model where you essentially add up one stressor, another stressor, another stressor, another stressor. And there is a breaking point for many people where just too many stressors handled all at once are really lead to problematic health outcomes. I thought it was interesting that overall what we found in Stress America
所以还有其他政策制定者可以更具创造性地思考如何创造我所说的这类工作机会。但我真的认为我们需要，尽管心理学是我们正在讨论的重要部分，但我们需要超越心理学走向政策，以解决这一代人面临的压力类型。好吧，让我们希望有一些重要的政策制定者正在收听这个播客并将其放在心上，因为这非常重要。所以我要感谢您今天加入我们，亚当博士。与您交谈非常有趣。非常感谢，金。您可以在我们的网站 www.combeckiq 上或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。
was that people felt positive about their future, but there was an exception among the Generation Z, what did they say about their futures? Well, you know, every generation in the Stress in America survey said they do feel hopeful for their future when they're asked specifically, but the Gen Z were the lowest on that. I think they were 64% or as compared to numbers in the 70s for the other individuals. So they have hope for their future, but the real psychological dimension that I think defines Gen Z in this survey is feelings of uncertainty about their future. They talk about two-thirds of them in the survey said that planning for their future seems impossible or feels
如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作，我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
impossible. And this was actually only 51% of Gen Z teen said that. So two-thirds feeling planning for the future feels impossible is a really paralyzing state. And uncertainty, I say, said that social exclusion is one thing that's really a powerful contribute to biological stress. The other is uncertainty. And so these teams are both socially isolated as well as feeling great degrees of uncertainty about what their future schooling is going to look like and also what their future jobs are going to look like. And I think, you know, there's real cause for concern about that. I have a colleague, Hannah Schwant, who has actually studied the impact of individuals graduating into a recession and has found that there is lifelong impacts of graduating into a
是不可能的。实际上只有51%的Z世代青少年这么说。因此，三分之二的人觉得为未来做规划是不可能的，这是一种非常令人瘫痪的状态。我说过，不确定性，社会排斥是导致生物压力的一种强有力的因素。另一个因素就是不确定性。所以这些青少年既感到社会孤立，又对他们未来的学业和未来的工作感到极大的不确定性。我认为，这确实令人担忧。我的一位同事汉娜·施万特（Hannah Schwant）研究了个人在经济衰退期间毕业的影响，发现这会对毕业生的终身收入，甚至包括家庭组建和健康结果产生终身影响。
recession on lifelong earnings as well as on even things like family formation and health outcomes. And so I think in addition to providing the types of emotional supports that we know are needed by teens and young adults, we also should be thinking really carefully about what kind of economic supports we can provide, what kind of job training programs, what kind of opportunities. I was brainstorming this morning and thinking, well, what about AmeriCorps? You know, could we have an expansion of AmeriCorps? Just have not only opportunities for teens and young adults that are graduating into this difficult economy, but opportunities that would be helpful for our country as a whole.
因此，我认为除了提供我们所知的青少年和年轻人所需的情感支持外，我们还应该非常认真地思考我们可以提供什么样的经济支持，什么样的职业培训项目，以及什么样的机会。我今天早上在集思广益，心想，美国志愿队（AmeriCorps）怎么样？我们是否可以扩大美国志愿队的规模？不仅为在这一困难经济形势下毕业的青少年和年轻人提供机会，而且提供对我们整个国家都有帮助的机会。
So there's other policymakers that can think much more creatively about how to create the types of job opportunities I'm talking about. But I really think that we need to, even though psychology is an important part of what we're talking about, we need to move beyond psychology to policy in order to address the types of stresses that this generation is facing. Well, let's hope that there are some important policymakers who are listening to this podcast and are taking this to heart because it's very important. So I want to thank you for joining us today, Dr. Adam. It's been very interesting talking with you. Thank you very much, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckiq or wherever you get your podcasts.
因此，还有其他决策者可以更有创造性地思考如何创造我所说的这类就业机会。但我真的认为，尽管心理学是我们讨论的重要组成部分，但我们需要超越心理学，转向政策，以解决这一代人所面临的各种压力。好吧，让我们希望有一些重要的决策者正在收听这个播客，并将其铭记在心，因为这非常重要。所以我要感谢亚当博士今天加入我们。与您交谈非常有趣。非常感谢你，金。您可以在我们的网站 www.combeckiq 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman, our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。即 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作，我们的音效编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Kondyne）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。